ich will einfach noch mal so dieses den
fokus darauf lenken worum geht es
eigentlich mit dieser waffenlieferung
langfristig denn natürlich ist niemand
hier im raum daran interessiert dass
dieser krieg sich endlos hinzieht es
muss darum gehen dass wir natürlich dass
es zu einer friedensverhandlungen kommt
das ist die
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen kommt
aber auch dafür ich wiederhole mich ein
bisschen sind natürlich waffenlieferung
notwendig denn ich glaube nicht dass
putin erst einlenkt wenn die gesamte
welt gegen ihn steht ich glaube dann
haben wir schlechte karten denn er hat
verbündete bei denen ich nicht darauf
wetten würde dass sie irgendwann gegen
ihn stehen
aber er wird dann einlenken wenn er
einfach keine militärischen erfolge mehr
wirklich sichtbar erzielen kann und wenn
er vielleicht so einen kleinen
achtungserfolg selbst verkaufen kann vor
vor vor seinem land vor und darum will
ich einfach nochmal betonen warum es
wirklich wichtig ist dass man das
deutschland hat ein bisschen mutiger
würden die bundesregierung ein bisschen
mehr
voran kommt und ich glaube genau
deswegen ist es eben auch wichtig dass
politik nicht nach umfragen gemacht wird
also ja die umfragen zum thema
waffenlieferung die haben sich
sicherlich verändert in den letzten
wochen und monaten aber das kann ja
nicht der maßstab sein der maßstab muss
sein und klar das oberste ziel ist wir
wollen alle so schnell wie möglich dass
dieser krieg endet aber ich und ich
glaube auch viele andere in diesem land
vertreten eben die überzeugung dass
putin nicht die die die sprache der
schwäche entsprechend honoriert sondern
die sprache der stärke und das heißt
waffenlieferungen und gerade schwere
waffenlieferungen macht sich niemand
einfach aber sie sind eben momentan
zwingend notwendig und die
bundesregierung hat das gesagt hat jede
woche vor allem oder eben maßgeblich die
spd in der andere ausrede gefunden warum
es jetzt gerade irgendwie nicht geht
erst hieß es wir haben nichts von der
verteidigungsministerin komischerweise
haben wir jetzt irgendwas doch für den
ringtausch da dann hieß es ja das würde
eben entsprechend weiter eskalieren
komisch aber wenn andere nato-staaten
trotzdem bereit sind genau das jahr zu
tun andere staaten haben sie schon
bekannt entsprechend schwer schwere
waffen zu liefern
deswegen wir haben eine internationale
verantwortung an der stelle und auch
glaube ich eine will also da gibt
verlässlichkeit die wir irgendwie
darstellen müssen gerade als deutschland
und der werden wir im eben momentan
nicht gerecht und ich bin mir auch
sicher hätten wir als union diese woche
den antrag nicht eingebracht im
deutschen bundestag gebe es keinen
antrag der ampelkoalition
der jetzt entsprechend diese woche
entschieden wird da bin ich mir nicht
ganz so sich also ich glaube was die spd
angeht und ihre zerrissenheit was das
thema angeht ja das ist offensichtlich
ich glaube aber das ist die beiden
koalitionspartner gibt die selbst ein
sehr großes interesse haben das thema
voranzubringen und jemand wie frau
strack zimmermann als sehr engagiert und
zwar von anfang an da fortschritte zu
machen also ihre kritik an der spd da
gehe ich mit aber ihre kritik an der
gesamten koalition da würde ich jetzt
ein bisschen dagegen räumt er ist wieder
in der leitung danach darfst du direkt
und die beruhigen nur noch einmal zurück
das er gerade kurz rausgeflogen aus der
leitung jetzt sollte er wieder da sein
dann würde ich ihn nämlich direkt einmal
fragen wie er das sieht so gesehen ein
schiedsrichter zwischen den beiden damen
ist
ob ich gut als schiedsrichter bin weiß
ich nicht aber tatsächlich glaube ich
ist bei der frage von frau
strack-zimmermann eine interessante
entwicklung zu betrachten denn frau
strack zimmermann war es die haben
anfang des krieges gesagt hat sinngemäß
kann das genaue zitat nicht mehr dass
das doch jetzt auch nichts mehr bringe
der ukraine zu helfen weil russland den
krieg ja ohnehin ganz schnell gewinnen
würde innerhalb von tagen das war ja
damals die meinung und deswegen würde
ich tatsächlich den optimismus
den tragischen optimismus und muss man
es fast nennen der amerikaner dass die
ukraine diesen krieg gewinnen kann aus
ihrer sicht tatsächlich teilen denn die
russische armee ist sehr viel schlechter
als die internationale gemeinschaft
angenommen hat und die ukraine sehr viel
stärker was die innenpolitische debatte
angeht da finde ich die spd
spricht für sich selbst die
zerrissenheit zerstrittenheit heute
morgen sagen herr mützenich und der
kühnert noch dass er auf keinen fall
panzerlieferung gibt dann am nachmittag
gibt es die also das ist ein chaos dass
ich mir diese spd und die hat schon viel
chaos erlebt kaum hätte vorstellen
können aber welche partei für mich den
wirklich überraschenden eindruck macht
ist die geschlossenheit der grünen also
wir dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass das
mal eine grund pazifistische partei war
und als es um den kosovo krieg ging
damals mit joschka fischer ist heftige
debatten gab in der partei und die
nämlich gar nicht mehr wahr aber die
grünen nämlich verstanden haben das will
man freiheit und demokratie waren will
dass das am ende gegen einen aggressor
putin eben nicht mit ausschließlich mit
verhandlungen geht sondern erst einmal
militärisch und deswegen finde ich auch
die grünen insbesondere annalena
baerbock und robert habeck der übrigens
schon im sommer also vor den wahlen hier
defensivwaffen für die ukraine gefordert
hat die spielen eine wirklich sehr sehr
positive rolle momentan und werden ja
auch von deutschen von der deutschen
bevölkerung in dem sinne belohnt das
annalena baerbock mittlerweile die
beliebteste politikerin oder ministerin
deutschlands ist sie sagen von waffen
für den waffenstillstand die position
ist mir sehr sympathisch weil es geht ja
gar nicht anders ja aber das führt uns
in ein dilemma rein das müssen wir jetzt
schon sehen wenn es ein waffenstillstand
gibt den muss russland zustimmen dem
wird putin nur dann zustimmen wenn er
den militärischen stand er dann erreicht
ist als sein sieg verkaufen kann er muss
also etwas geholt haben dann wirkt der
aggressor sozusagen belohnt und zwar
durch land gewinnen das müssen wir sehen
er wird glaube ich erst an einem
waffenstillstand zustimmen wenn die ost
ukraine an ihnen gefallen es und einen
landstreifen im süden der ukraine
entlang über mario pohl die stadt wird
er auch kann wir wollen bis hin zur krim
damit eine landverbindung zur krim hat
das ist das was er jetzt will ob er
früher mal die ganze ukraine wollte hat
er gesagt weiß ich nicht aber das ist
jetzt jedenfalls ein kriegsziel und
stimmen wir dem dann zu dass er die ost
ukraine bekommt ich meine zu erkennen
dass es in westlichen hauptstädten ich
weiß nicht ob in allen aber in
westlichen hauptstädten auch in berlin
das unausgesprochene konzept gibt einer
politischen lösung die genau das
beinhaltet
deshalb auch liefert man nicht
entschlossen richtig wichtige waffen und
moderne waffen sondern man ist dabei
irgendwie altes gerät fit zu machen
damit man damit man sich nicht ständig
den vorwurf anhören muss dass man nichts
täten aber man will in wahrheit nichts
tun sondern das ist das ziel das
politische kriegsziel heißt putin krieg
der ost ukraine und dann ist frieden und
dann sind die russisch orientierten auch
russisch sprechenden leuten fallen kann
russland in oslo keine und die west
ukraine wo kiew liegt nah an polen darf
in die eu eintreten der rest wird
neutral das scheint mir in berlin
gedacht zu werden das meint er stolz
wenn er sagt wenn ich nichts tue ist das
auch führung das ist kein witz das ist
auch nicht zynisch muss sondern das ist
vielleicht ernst gemeint naja aber es
gibt doch mittlerweile auch situationen
in denen technische soldaten an neuen
waffen techniken neue waffentechnologie
ausgebildet werden das sind alle
rutschen
hosen machen das und einige
osteuropäische länder
und da sieht man doch dass es aus meiner
sicht nicht so eindeutig ist dass man
sich hinter so ein paar alten panzern
versteckt und die nach vorne schiebt um
irgendwie raus zu kommen als das in
berlin schon berlin ist am nächsten an
moskau im ort nach wie vor es gibt keine
zeitenwende dieses vorgetäuscht die gibt
es nicht das denken in berlin geht nach
wie vor da hin zu sagen wir werden
später noch mal mit putin reden müssen
dieses denken beinhaltet nicht wir
müssen putin beseitigen und dann können
wir wieder mit russland reden sondern
werden mit putin reden müssen und
deshalb müssen wir uns bestimmte kanäle
offen halten das ist ok er hat doch auch
schon und die muster übrigens auch zum
bestandteil eines waffenstillstand seien
entsprechende kriterien mehr oder
weniger definiere mit bezug auf die
creme mit ihren angeboten ukraine mit
bezug eben darauf kein nato
mitgliedsstaat zu werden aber die
perspektive eu beitritt und die per also
dass wir am ende diese politische lösung
dass die irgendwie zu stande kommen muss
ist ja nicht falsch und trotzdem glaube
ich muss man sich der frage stellen wie
verhindert man dass es nicht darüber
hinausgeht weil ich glaube wenn putin
die möglichkeit hat mehr zu bekommen als
das dann wird er das auf jeden fall
versuchen und das ist glaube ich der
punkt den wir beantworten müssen und da
ist zurückhaltung von deutscher seite
meines erachtens momentan die falsche
bahn
ein der sich auch noch an der debatte
beteiligen möchte ich muss das ja hier
fühlen er kann ja leider nicht im studio
sein ich bin froh wenn er wieder hier
ist
ja hoch spannende debatte und vor allem
und ich stimme dir voll zu das ist auch
das was ich aus dem politischen berlin
ihre seit beginn des krieges schon davor
ich glaube man hat schon vor beginn des
krieges versucht residenz gehen
irgendeine art von
verhandlungslösungen zu drücken
neutralität wie österreich das wir ja
noch halb so schlimm kann man sagen dann
geht es dann um die frage aber wie viel
militär erlaubt in russland aber noch
viel schlimmer sind
die gebietsabtritte die man aus sicht
des westens dann leisten müsste und hier
kommt eine ganz wichtige komponente dazu
man redet immer über
friedensverhandlungen selensky und putin
die müssen dann an einem tisch sitzen an
den tisch sitzen aber am ende auch 40
millionen ukraine und das was ich hier
war neben im land ist nicht dass man
bereit ist auf städte auf regionen zu
verzichten wo freunde wo verwandte wo
die ehefrau wo der ehemann getötet wurde
ermordet wurde hingerichtet wurde das
was wir in butter gesehen haben ist
wahrscheinlich im vergleich zu dem was
wirklich in mario pohl passiert ist gar
nichts das heißt die bereitschaft hier
auf irgendeine art von
verhandlungslösung ist wirklich sehr
sehr gering natürlich will man dass der
krieg aufhört aber man sagt und das ist
ein argument glaube ich was man sehr
ernst nehmen muss was wäre denn wenn wir
russland jetzt ein bisschen geben wer
sagt uns denn dass russland dann aufhört
wer sagt uns denn dass nicht wieder
alles gebrochen wird wie 1994 als die
atomwaffen abgegeben wurden wie
verschiedene weitere
abkommen gebrochen wurden man traut
russland nicht man traute russland
deshalb nicht und man will dass alle
russischen truppen aus dem land
verschwinden und das gesamte territorium
wieder an die ukraine geht jetzt
unabhängig davon ob das realistisch ist
oder nicht das ist die stimmung in der
bevölkerung ist muss hieße in diesem
fall dass man sich damit abfindet der
aggressor macht beute in der ukraine
irgendwas wird dagegen damit der krieg
aufhört ich würde am liebsten nicht
diese realistische lösung sehen ich
hänge tut mir leid einer idealisten
lösung an ich würde gerne sehen dass der
aggressor rausgeworfen wird aus der
ukraine und zwar überall und zwar auch
von der krim dass man ihn besiegt ist
der die vokabel es ja mehrfach gefallen
aber mir scheint es im westen in den
nato statt insbesondere in berlin diese
entschlossenheit ihn zu besiegen nicht
zu geben